my Angelo said to me repeatedly that we
find our path by walking it we find our
path by walking it and at the end of the
day for all the advice you get from me
or anyone else from all the books you
read about how to live a good life your
best life from all the self-help
seminars that you go to and all the big
think programs that you watch at the end
of the day with all this information
coming at you you only find your path by
walking it you have to commit yourself
to being courageous being committed
being consistent to those immutable
principles by which you have decided you
are going to live your life there is no
other way around this you have to walk
your path to find it we live in a world
where everybody's looking for a shortcut
everybody wants to shortcut to success
the shortcut to this the shortcut to
that in our cars I live in LA we use
these apps to find the shortest way to
get to where we're going everybody in
life these days it seems is trying to
find a shortcut to wherever they think
they're trying to go and often times
when we shortcut our way to getting
there
we're not happy when we arrive anyway
and oftentimes certainly in terms of our
lives and careers it means less if you
have cheated or shortcutted your way to
get there anyway
my point is that there's no alternative
to doing the work you have to do the
work and doing the work means and you
have to walk the walk you have to walk
the path if you're going to find and
discover what your life is truly all
about and quite frankly I'll close on
this note I've discovered that the joy
is in the walk anyway the joy is in the
journey there is joy in the journey
there are ups and their downs but
there's joy in the journey I believe
that we live in a society where we are
so caught up with achieving milestones
that we end up missing the
moments you know milestones are a
beautiful thing but it's these moments
that really make life worth living so
don't be so you know caught up in
chasing milestones in your career that
you missed the important moments along
the way